how is being an artist very different
from being the audience
that is one of the hardest things to get
used to because we all begin as an
audience there i don't think there's an
artist in the world who didn't start by
being a fan
we all want to do these things because
we liked seeing them absorbing them
we were the best consumers
and
the truth is
the artist never experiences their own
work the way an audience will because
they first you know what's going to
happen you can't actually experience it
you have to reverse engineer that whole
experience just like if you were if
you're building a roller coaster
you can't be riding the roller coaster
at the same time you have to actually
say i need a support here and i need a
dip here and you're being very
mechanical and frankly artificial about
it because you're saying i want them to
get a throw when they go over that hoop
hump
and
and in order to do that i'm going to
have to have this amount of force up
here and then it's going to have to have
a
tailing out at that point and it's going
to become very mechanical in order to
give somebody else the pleasure of
riding that roller coaster
that's what you need to do as an artist
is to say
i love the experience of going over that
hump and then zooming down
and for some reason i don't crash at the
bottom that's because someone knew how
to get out of the freefall that i'm
going through
the artist has to stop and learn the
mechanics
how you support the track that's going
to do that how you make the story twist
and turn and provoke those experiences
that you yourself will never have
and
when you're actually doing it you get
this weird kind of duality because as
you're creating you usually have like a
little tiny bit of an audience's
experience you'll be like
i'm actually enjoying the line i just
thought of as an audience did you'll
have that for a fraction of a second
while you're doing it um and then after
that you have to figure out the
mechanics to make that scene work
um so you're constantly going back and
forth sort of saying i
want to be an audience now and now in
order to get that audience i got to go
back and become the mechanic and you're
constantly cycling through them you can
never really give up being an audience
but you have to also become
the person building the ride
the other thing about artists and
audiences
is that
from the finished product you can never
tell how it got made
one of the things i think artists really
should do is try to read or hear
podcasts or books about how things you
love got made because you'll always be
amazed at how the people who set out to
do it did not know that the final result
was going to be what we now think of as
inevitable and the the stories are
actually i just read one about midnight
cowboy and and when they brought the
book midnight cowboy john schlesinger
the director and the producer brought
the book to mgm the studio and they said
we want to do this
very dark story about this wannabe
hustler going to times square and mgm
said
we think this could be an elvis presley
vehicle and we're going to put in some
songs and we'll take out that dark stuff
so
you know
on a bad day mgm could have taken it
over and it could have been elvis
presley in midnight cowboy which would
have been something to see
but the point is when we watch midnight
cowboy it never occurs to us
how many different things had to go
right or had to be learned to make that
happen and having worked
behind the scenes having created things
i can tell you that there are things
that i did not know going in somebody
brought it to me sometimes whole story
ideas were not my idea in fact
the script i'm best known for fracture
wasn't my original script someone else
had written a very very good script the
studio wanted to make changes someone
else was hired after that then i was
brought in so many of the plot twists i
didn't come up with i did a lot of the
writing that made those plot twists work
in that form that it did end up in but
when you watch that movie you come to me
and say how did you think of that plot
twist the answer is i read it in
somebody else's script and i used it
because that's the job
so the answer is
you can't just look at stuff you love
and go oh i know how they did that
you'll never know how they did that and
you'll never know how your work is going
to come out you just don't you have to
get used to the experience of trying to
get something done
doing the best you can
and seeing how it plays
you had talked about something in the
artistic process
abstract to concrete to abstract
yes what is that um that's sort of a
follow-up of the artist um
artist audience issue which is
you nothing will ever come out like it
feels to you
that is part of the art i don't i don't
think there's any artist who hasn't
gotten hopefully used to it because it's
part of learning how to do it
um one of the things that
brought this to me was i was once
looking at a picasso drawing and late
picasa drawings especially are just like
they're like scribbles you know it's it
looks sort of like a bull but
how did he know to make the line go like
how did he know to do that because it's
just a scribble but it's a bull
and i suddenly realized he didn't know
he knew that whatever came out would be
interesting he trusted that and that's
what every artist has to learn that you
don't know exactly how it's going to
come out you can outline i outline
incredibly thoroughly and i think i know
what's going to happen but the truth is
that there's going to be a process after
that the creative process
good word for it you're creating
something out of nothing and when that
happens it's going to be something that
you're going to discover as you do it
and then you need to shape it and rework
it and do all the other things that
artists have to do
but
the thing in your head there's this
feeling or this idea or this line
and then you put it on the page
and then somebody else performs it and
then someone else sees it and in all of
those steps it's not what you thought it
was going to be and the best thing an
artist can do is get really comfortable
in a sense getting comfortable with a
failure you're going to fail to get your
exact feeling and thought out to someone
else
that's that's life it will never ever
happen that someone gets exactly what
you thought it was but what will happen
is you'll get used to doing that
scribble and someone will go oh cool
bowl and that's art that's the magic of
it is that you get used to bringing
something abstract into a concrete form
and someone else gets an abstract
experience out of it that's
that's something that only art does it's
beautiful
so get used to
sounds like just experimenting and and
trusting that i may not know where it's
going but this kind of feels right and
knowing that that same thing you could
see it
could be changed drastically and you
have to be collaborative and okay with
that
get used to the process get used to the
experience of doing the thing
over and over if you're playing tennis
you get used to hitting the ball you hit
it over and over and then eventually
you'll get to where you can control it
more but still there's going to be a lot
of other elements and what only thing
that you can get used to is the process
of making the swing likewise the process
of thinking of something writing it in a
concrete form editing it
shaping it rewriting it giving it to
other people that process that's what
you have to practice that's what you
have to get to enjoy and feel comfort in
and the more that you do it the more
that you'll get lucky and things will
work out and you'll be like oh i think
this line is funny and then you write it
down and someone reads it and they laugh
that gives you so much
power for the next time you do it
because sometimes it's going to work and
sometimes it's going to not work but
the more you do it
the more it will work
you